all right Angie yes Angie where'd you
grow up where are you from originally oh
goodness this is going to be
embarrassing for anybody that sees it
here
um Decatur Illinois Macon County home of
the soybean fields
please don't let anybody hear that part
though people down here know my Yankee
it'll be over with for me
tell me about your family
um okay so my mom was two years older
than my dad
um my dad was just kind of like a
pothead and you know his
lazy dude whatever mom got with him
she got pregnant he took off while she
was pregnant
so she kept me for about three years and
then dumped me with my grandma because
she was a drug addict you know pretty
much like my story you know drug addict
prostitute whatever lifestyle just kind
of crazy
um my Grandma had me and my two net or
my two nephews wait nephew no cousins
not my nephews my cousins and um
she had us until we were I was about 10
and then my dad came back and had gotten
remarried and I guess decided that he
wanted to have you know his family or
whatever so he got me and uh that lasted
for like two years until I ran away
because the Stepmom thing you know
but uh as far as like you know up until
that point when I ran away though like
even bouncing around from like my
grandma to my dad like night and my life
was normal like as a kid like great
Christmases family vacations you know
what I'm saying like my dad was in the
Army so nothing dramatic yeah no not at
all well no I did you know have a um
somebody did sexually abuse me my mom's
second husband before my grandma got me
but I mean I was young I mean I was like
three and four I don't actually remember
it I know that by the time we went to
court um because it happened in Dallas
Texas by the time we went to court for
it
um I was like seven and eight and uh
I mean I didn't really remember you know
all there was was just the hospital
reports you know the stuff that you know
and documented what had been done to me
you know physically or whatever
um
but I can't say that that like I said I
don't remember any of the abuse at all
you know like at all so
as far as childhood I was I was straight
you know it was and so my dad you know
got remarried and uh my stepmom I mean
resented I guess me because
you know she had two kids with them and
I guess I wasn't her kid so it was like
you know I don't want anything to do
with her and uh she was pretty pretty
abusive to me physically you know just
would do things like when my dad wasn't
around and
you know if you tell me things like you
know I was trying to [ __ ] my own dad and
you know I was going to be you know
pregnant by the time I was 13 and you
know just all these horrible things and
uh
you know So eventually I just couldn't
take it and I found out that my birth
you know my mom was in Texas and I got
on a bus and
showed up in Texas I literally just
showed up at 11 years old and called my
mom and told her I was at the bus stop
in Houston
and uh
that was that and then uh within a year
I was pregnant
I met this Mexican guy
that lived down the street from where my
mom lived and of course my mom didn't
want me there you know what I'm saying
so it was
just always fighting and arguing and
yelling and just you know like I would
come home from school and like she'd be
in the bedroom like [ __ ] a trick and
like I would try to knock on the door
and like she would like open the door
and like throw a radio at me and [ __ ]
you know what I'm saying someone get out
the [ __ ] house and whatever so I was
like okay well I'm not gonna put up with
this either so
I uh
I met just Mexican dude and uh next
thing you know I'm pregnant
and uh his we lived with his parents I
moved in with him and his parents and uh
you know Mexicans it's like the more
babies the better you know so it's like
seven months later I was pregnant seven
months after I met him okay so my first
son actually wasn't his
um I was you know very promiscuous and
uh I don't know who his father was I
mean I was just I was 11 years old 12
years old just [ __ ] you know like it
was nobody's business you know I
couldn't even begin to tell you know
Jordan who is dead his real father was
but
um
you know I met away and seven months
after I met him I was pregnant a year
and a half later I was pregnant again
um two years later I was pregnant again
I finished high school though my uh my
high school had a really great parenting
program because I was pregnant all
during the 90s and that was like when
the teenage pregnancy was like you know
running rampant or whatever and they had
a great program I'm so thankful for that
program at my school you know Miss
Powell and everything else I wouldn't
have graduated and I got to graduate
early 17. started a college at a
I'm a colleges in Mainland and Texas
City because I lived in Dickinson and um
I decided that I even though my dad was
never really in my life and I guess he
was like a letdown to me I wanted to be
like him you know he was a cop for
Mandeville he was in the Army for 26
years he you know retired command
sergeant major which is like oh wow you
know whatever
um so I thought maybe if I was like him
then maybe he would care about me you
know
so I went to school closing Mainland
started criminal justice
and uh the head of the criminal justice
maybe I shouldn't say any name so the
head of the criminal justice department
there was a former head of the sex
crimes unit for the FBI
and uh
that was the first trick I returned oh
wow
yeah I thought that we were just going
to go I thought if I [ __ ] him I was
going to you know pretty much be
guaranteed
you know better job with the co-op you
know because I was co-oping and you know
wanted to do the work at the police
station and everything and I wanted to
work at the best police station there in
Galveston County which was League City
at the time and I was like okay well
I [ __ ] my you know
[ __ ] my professor I'll get everything
that I need to do in school and
when uh he walked out he laid down two
100 bills on the dresser
and I was like what is that for Mr
Kettler and he was like probably the
lifestyle you're better suited for
and uh
yeah he was right
um
so
my
ex-husband ended up making my kid's
father ended up molesting a girl in the
neighborhood a seven-year-old girl
and uh unbeknownst to me he had a crack
habit and uh I at this point I've never
been on any drugs or anything in my life
you know I said I'm going to college I'm
you know I'm doing everything right and
uh
he was smoking crack and molested one of
the neighborhood girls and uh got caught
and uh he ended up in prison in Texas
and uh he still has to be like on the
sex offender registry so he could never
be around my kids after that or our kids
after that
um
and that's like really hard to deal with
you know because it's like oh [ __ ] how
the hell are you married to somebody
like this that you know and he was only
a year older than me so it's not like
you know he was anything weird between
us or whatever
but anyway so
you know my kids stayed with his parents
and at first I was staying with them and
you know after a while
you know there are two feelings about me
came out and you know they pushed me out
of the house so
my four boys stayed behind
um
and uh
I just kind of got tossed out into the
world
and uh
and went to go work at a a bar in
Houston did everybody call the pony bar
and I didn't really know what that was
but I just knew that it was a Mexican
place and the white girls would get
hired really easy and you can make a lot
of money and all you had to do was just
let the guys buy you drinks every drink
that a guy bought you you got a ticket
and it was like the guy paid 20 for the
drink and you got a ticket and you got
ten dollars at the end of the night
and uh quickly found out that that was
just like undercover for like Mexican
whorehouse
and uh so I I mean it wasn't even like a
thought like to start tricking like it
was just like
all the Mexicans all this money and like
a white girl and it's like oh my God you
know just you know they think that we're
Queens like you know these are like what
we call Pisces you know like they're
fresh to the country they you know they
they'll do anything to get a white girl
so I mean I made so much money that it
was just ridiculous like I didn't even
know it was possible to make money like
that and uh
doing that you know out there in Houston
at that time that was like in 1997 98 99
there was no internet stuff yet
um but there was a lot of pimps and uh
so I quickly met one and got a got
introduced to that whole lifestyle which
I don't really like pimps when it comes
to The Pimps I don't care if a girl has
a pimp or what you know it's not for me
anymore
um but there's some really good pimps
out there and there's some really
[ __ ] shitty ones
um it just depends on how you know what
type I guess female you are you know
because in the beginning you know I
didn't do drugs and I was just checking
for the money you know so it was like
completely different my first pimp was
uh his name was Andre McDaniels he uh we
called him Dre he
owned a bunch of uh massage parlors in
Houston so all the girls worked in
studios they didn't work out on the
street and uh
that was great I mean that was great
like from the time I was 20 to the time
I was 25 I think I was with him and uh
then we were just all sitting in there
one day in the studio and like the feds
and all these people run up in the place
and they take Dre and Pookie and Big
John and uh Pookie's you know girlfriend
and then the feds are coming in and all
of us girls are just like sitting there
he's got 19 girls you know
you know
that was scary because it's like well
our whole life just got taken away all
the money we've made I mean I've been
within five years everything I had
developed in the last five years has
gone and you're not getting it back and
what the [ __ ] do you do now
we can't even go home you know
so uh
I quickly figured that one out you know
and uh
by that time internet had had hit you
know and there was Craigslist and
Backpage and all that stuff and so I
stayed around Houston for a while and
like did the you know the uh Studio
thing and uh
then I met my second pimp and uh
I was with him for three years
and then uh he got arrested for human
trafficking he was bringing back girls
from Guatemala
and uh that was [ __ ] crazy because I
sure never saw that side of him
um
I actually saw one of your girls that
you would interview I told you she had
the same tattoo as me YP
um that's I don't know if she knew that
but yeah he ended up going to prison
he's still in the feds now for you know
bringing back underage Guatemalan girls
crazy never thought that it's just so
weird how you can just know people and
never know like some of the things that
they do you know
um so once again it was like well what
the [ __ ] you know here I am just stuck
out I'm losing everything you know
that's when uh
I just started running with a bunch of
independent girls and
you know these girls were
I guess because they had no direction in
their life they were just getting high I
was like turn a trick to Get High Get
High to turn a trick and you know so I
started getting high first thing I did
was a coat I used to shoot up coke first
and I went straight to the needle first
you know I saw these girls smoking on a
pipe and all this [ __ ] and then I saw a
girl shooting up and I was like well she
looks like she feels a lot better so I
want to do that in a shop Coke for three
years and then uh got turned out on
heroin there was a at that time I was
there was a flood in Baton Rouge and um
it was shut down it was like a hurricane
had come through and for some reason it
like flooded Baton Rouge really bad and
I was out there working in Baton Rouge
off the internet and um
it was crazy because like I was shooting
up Coke and I remember my dealer was
like yeah I'll come out as long as
you're getting like 300 or more and like
there's no Hotel there's nobody has
generators nothing like all the lights
are off in Baton Rouge like you know
it's just
dark you know and here I am in a hotel
room just like shooting up shooting up
shooting up shooting up Coke and uh so
uh
I went to go buy some more coke and uh
his girlfriend actually gave me a bag of
heroin she I guess she couldn't tell
which one was which and uh I went back
and I shot up the heroin and it was like
okay yep well this is it you know uh
I guess I kind of missed the point in
the story where my ex in-laws you know
they kind of eventually brainwashed my
kids against me you know and uh I was
supporting it was crazy because I was
supporting them and my children and uh
you know they just I think they had a
lot of resentment towards me they really
in their heart felt that I made ray
smoke crack you know that was the whole
thing it was like I've never even done
any drugs at that point I had nothing to
do with him doing that like he was not
only you know messing around on me like
doing all that behind my back you know
what I'm saying but like I wasn't you
know so they did everything in their
power to keep my kids for me and you
know when you're 12 years old and you
have a child and you know what I'm
saying like
you know nine years later all of your
kids get taken away from you that's all
you know that's what I grew up knowing
you know what I'm saying I know I don't
want to cry
um
and you don't understand you know like
my mom wasn't there for me and that was
cool you know whatever I had a good
grandma but my dad wasn't there you know
I'm saying that like my dad I thought
you know he didn't like me or whatever
I know from the first moment I had my
child it was just like wow you know you
created a life and
and then all of a sudden somebody takes
it away
and I I really wasn't doing anything
that honestly I felt deserved that you
know and uh
I started getting high and it was like
[ __ ]
you know I don't have to think about
this
now I have to feel this
but along with
you know the drugs poems the lifestyle
that's
very different you know
um
you could go for being on the internet
making three four hundred dollars an
hour
but when the calls aren't coming in and
you know you go out on them streets and
it's like you got to do anything to get
high
you know that's when the [ __ ] starts
happening you know I've been
picked up off the street and you know
gone into an apartment empty apartment
building to turn a trick with one guy
and then all of a sudden there's five of
them walking in and you know like I've
when it comes to you I'm sure you've
heard all types of crazy stories you
know like who wants to dwell on all that
[ __ ] but it just I guess comes with the
territory you know I've been robbed and
raped you know what I'm saying all that
crazy [ __ ] over and over eventually it
gets to the point where it's like you're
gonna rape me okay just please wear a
condom you know like I don't even care
you know so what you know you just
become so desensitized to sex you know
what I'm saying and like
relationships and all that [ __ ] you know
never had a successful relationship
because first of all you know like who
wants to have a prostitute as a
girlfriend and if they do there's
probably something kind of [ __ ] wrong
with them you know they're obviously not
going to be very good for you anyway
you know and uh so I've always been
alone and just you know but the drugs
are just it's kept me from you know
my kids you know just
that's just always been my number one
problem and
no matter what I tried to do you know
and by a certain point they've grown up
and I've been trying for so long to get
back in their lives and you know now
they're 15 16 18 you know and they're
doing their own thing you know and it's
like
how do you fix a relationship
you know when my oldest one knows the
truth and me and him are are straight
we're good but you know my other three
you know they just know that Mom just
left you know and it's like it's so
funny because I don't give it they're
cool with their dad you know what I'm
saying like they write this man in
prison and [ __ ]
and uh it's like how the hell are you
okay with somebody that molested a girl
but your mom that actually tried you
know like y'all think I'm some type of
horrible you know drug addict that just
don't want to be with their kids and
that's not true I was you know I didn't
lose him because I was a drug addict you
know I started doing the drugs
eventually because I didn't have them
you know and
after a while you just it's just the
same thing over and over it just becomes
repetitive you know and it my thing is
I would love to quit doing this and you
know have a normal life again because
that's definitely what I had in the
beginning but
now it's just like after tricking for so
long all the stuff I've seen with these
men you know and just
their opinions of women and the [ __ ]
that I do and uh
the other girls that I've hung out with
and become friends with and
all the things I've seen you know it
just kind of changes your
perspective on things and like what's
really important you know material
things definitely are not important you
know because you lose that over and over
and over again you know I've been
homeless on the streets living in Bandos
in San Antonio
you know I've actually that's where I
was two years ago you know and uh I got
myself a or when covet happened I got
scared I kind of got scared a little bit
I was like well [ __ ] I need to get a
place to live but uh you know and um
it just sucks because
I would like to quit doing all this and
just have a normal life but now to me in
normal life seems just as boring and
[ __ ] miserable as the life I have now
so it's like at least now I've got the
drugs to just [ __ ]
keep you numb
you know but um
is your normal life scary
I think any life is scary I mean
what's your biggest fear right now my
biggest fear
oh
goodness
did
I don't think I even have a big fear I
really don't
not making any money to get my heroin I
want to be dope sick
you know like I told you you know like
how do you change it you know when you
get so far into it how do you change it
because it's like who's gonna pay the
bill so that I can detox
who's gonna pay the bills until I get a
job and can get that first paycheck
and it's not that it's hard it's not
hard everybody goes well you know you
just need you know people just think
that we're just so like weak or we just
don't want to do things it's not that
it's just how do you you know who's
going to help you when you come to this
point in your life
people don't really care about you
anymore
you know most you know most people I
know like me most of us working girls
and stuff we don't have family
and the only family or friends we have
are other you know Street people and
yeah they'll be your friends and you can
say hey that's my best friend but honest
to God given a chance to [ __ ] you over
so they can get some drug money they're
gonna do it in a heartbeat you know so
there's just nobody in your corner how
do you change
you know and people may say well that's
kind of a you know an easy way out you
know to say that but
well if somebody tells me that I'll try
it you know I'm not afraid to try
you know
um don't know if a normal life would be
any better than this one is until you
know
I get the help I need you know because I
have you know mental issues or whatever
you know
I definitely have a
mental health problems but like in
prison you know they try to put me on
you know psych meds and stuff like that
and
and then I'm just like sober and I'm
like medicated but I'm not like numb and
it's just like
[Music]
um
talking to somebody how does that how
does that change anything that happened
you know like you go to therapy it's
like okay you're on segment and you go
to therapy it's how does that change in
the things that have happened to you
like
until you can find a way to erase those
memories from somebody's head how do
they really change the way they feel
especially at 44 I've felt this way you
know preach my whole [ __ ] life how do
you change that you know like I said if
somebody tells me I'll try you know
maybe it'd be better to have a normal
life you know
but
what's a normal life paying your bills
you know uh getting up and going to work
you know uh well I pay my bills and I
get up and go to work yeah sometimes the
money's slow and you know I might be
dope sick or whatever and
then that trick calls and yeah you feel
like [ __ ] but you just get up and do it
you know what I mean like I I'm not
homeless anymore I have an apartment and
I have a dog who's amazing you know
and I kind of got him just to prove that
I could take care of something you know
just wanted to make sure I wasn't
selfish being selfish anymore I guess
because uh I was spending all my money
on drugs for real
but I even do now you know like other
than my rent like
and food you know it's funny though
because everybody in the neighborhood
says I'm like the most responsible drug
addict I'm like the one that everybody
like comes in my house to take a shower
and you know what I mean like
shoot up in my bathroom and all the
stupid [ __ ] that goes along with it but
uh I've always got food in the
refrigerator and you know blankets in
the winter and the hurricane all the
homeless people come and stay with me
um so I'm definitely considering the
most responsible drug addict in our
little neighborhood there in Mid-City
but uh
you know
what do you do
you been alive before in love
uh no
because when I got married as a kid I
was you know I was 13 when I got married
like you know that we weren't in love we
didn't even know what love was yet and
then I've been doing this ever since I
was 20 so I've had boyfriends and uh I
married a trick which is you know the
number one rule don't do that
um but that was he just had told me you
know I'll basically let you sit in the
house all day and buy all your drugs and
you just don't have a life and just be
here for me and I did that for like a
year and a half and it was like oh [ __ ]
no this sucks but uh
no I don't think being in love would
make me any happier I know love I know
what love is for sure I know what
unconditional love is you know I'm a
mother I have children
um
can I have some more tissue please sorry
um but being in love isn't something
that I care about uh I don't know that
might be a you know a product of being
abused as a child and then you know
being a sex worker for the last 24 years
of my life but
I don't care about being in love
is that what's wrong with me
[Laughter]
I've never been in love but now I
definitely know unconditional love
for sure
no
for sure I'm sorry so I definitely know
unconditional love I know what it is to
love you know and unconditionally love
these are your kids yeah [ __ ] right
oh yeah that's that's the greatest
feeling in the world you know I look at
them now they're you know they're
1921 24 and 26 and uh they've all turned
out pretty damn solid and uh that's
freaking amazing when you can create a
person and even if they grew up to be
[ __ ] or whatever I'd still love them
unconditionally you know what I'm saying
but it's just great to to make another
human being that's an amazing thing and
then just to watch them them grow
you know that's that's when I hear all
these stories about or even my own mom
my own I I call her Ellen I don't call
her mom but I didn't actually see her
again until I was like 32 so from the
time I was four to 32 I never saw the
woman
um and then one of my sisters got
pregnant and her husband wanted to find
out family history for medical reasons
and they searched Ellen and they found
her and I was living in Baton Rouge and
come to find out she was 25 minutes away
from me in reserve it was like holy [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
so like a couple weeks later and I hate
my sister Glenna for doing this she gave
Ellen my phone number and I get a call
and I answered my phone and like my
phone's a trick phone I don't have like
a personal reason and there's like a
broad on the other new line and I'm like
oh [ __ ] here's somebody's [ __ ] wife
calling the [ __ ] you know say some
stupid [ __ ] to me again and
and she's like Angela we're not like
okay nobody calls me Angela everybody
calls me Angie so I was like uh yes and
she's like it's your mother Ellen
and I was just like oh okay and
what do you want you know like
you know and I didn't know anything
about like her lifestyle or anything and
but I just didn't have any feelings for
you know what I'm saying I was like you
were never there like I said I ran away
to you know Houston with her but it was
only a matter of eight months before I
got pregnant and you know I left her
house because
she was just you know a different guy
different guy every day and her yelling
at me to get out of the house go sit on
the stairs you know what I'm saying and
like [ __ ] who wants to sit outside on
the stairs all day you know and uh I'm
just like there's no feeling for her
there you know and
she asked me to come you know see her
and you know she wanted to talk to me
and apologize to me for some things and
I was like okay I guess you know and
long story short I went to go meet her
and it was like oh my God
what the [ __ ] uh a woman was 62 years
old still walking River Road out there
in reserve turning tricks and just like
smoking crack like crazy not a single
tooth in her head nothing living in a
little travel trailer on her
ex-husband's property with about 15
[ __ ] chihuahuas
now that scares me
if I end up like Ellen I'll probably
shoot myself in the [ __ ] head that uh
but uh do you feel like you're walking
in your mom's footsteps no but it was
just crazy it's like how the [ __ ] have I
never been around this woman and I I'm a
prostitute that's addicted to drugs you
know I was like holy [ __ ] you know that
was pretty [ __ ] crazy so it's like is
this [ __ ] genetic are we all just
predisposed to be [ __ ] you know
losers or whatever like what the [ __ ]
you know but uh
um
that is my biggest fear that you know
what
back to that question mark that's my
biggest fear to end up like that woman
that's got to be miserable that's that
she's that's a horrible woman she's yeah
she's she did some shitty [ __ ] in her
life she lost every kid she ever had
um to be with men quite all of her
daughters were sexually abused all three
of us because I have two half-sisters
um
yeah that's definitely my biggest fear
but uh what else were we talking about
before that though sorry I didn't mean
to jump back to that tell me how you see
men do you see men differently you think
because of this job
then you know what I am like it doesn't
bother me whatever you want to do
sexually cool as long as you're not
messing with your little kids
you know or [ __ ] any [ __ ] dead
people or animals I really don't care I
I've seen so much stuff in this business
like I might laugh at you once you leave
you know and be like yeah you're kind of
[ __ ] weird dude like damn sorry it
takes all that to turn you on you know
but uh
other way I look at it is like you know
there's guys that do it because they're
lonely there's guys that do it just
because they're single and they have a
busy life they don't have time to go out
and find [ __ ] you know what I'm saying
they know they can just look pick and go
pay for it's easy you know it's done and
over with you know uh
married guys do it because you know sex
with their wife is boring I mean I
understand why all the guys do it really
doesn't bother me I'm a very empathic
person I'm very understanding of people
uh you know I'm not really judgmental
too much unless you just are a [ __ ] bag
um you know
um so
what's your biggest regret
damn
that's a tough one
uh
probably just
letting my in-laws I guess uh letting
them push me to the side like that
you know I I wish that uh I don't say
that I would regret having my children
Young
but I regret that I wasn't mature enough
um mentally
to know how to change that situation
with my with my kids
yeah damn you're gonna make me cry again
[ __ ] uh
yeah
I wish I would know what's happened so
easily
is that something that you can never
feel
that emptiness in your heart when your
kids aren't there
that's hard
I hate having to go on Facebook and find
out what they're doing and
that sucks
but
unfortunately we can't go back and
change anything you know
you're good what will you do differently
I said I I would not have let them push
me away
so easily
thinking that just because they were
older and married and you know
that they knew what was better
for my kids
um
and of course not getting involved with
the drugs
because it does numb you but
you know
like the song says when the drugs run
out
you know
and uh
you know there's times that you have to
be alone with your thoughts it sucks
you know that that sucks
so
I just wish it would have been different
when it comes to my kids you know that
whole situation
but uh
as far as this lifestyle
I don't really you know it doesn't
bother me like I said you get you know
used to it all the [ __ ] that happens on
the streets and
you know I could tell you all those
stories and you know
make my whole little story so much more
traumatic and stuff but
you know that every we all know what
happens to Street girls you know what
I'm saying like I don't want to be just
another one in 15 million that you know
we all have those stories you know what
I'm
saying
we all have those stories
Angie what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
oh wow
oh
not to not to judge people
um
because even though I may say
you know you shouldn't you know
shouldn't judge us people that do what
we do and stuff you know I can often be
very judgmental you know and be like
what the [ __ ] is that person's problem
you know what's wrong with them you know
why are they doing that and you know
don't they just know I think I know how
to fix everybody's problems with my own
you know I'm one of those people
um so I wish that I you know
there wouldn't be such a judgmental
person I guess
that's my there's my one downfall
especially when they say uh
so what's that saying about not calling
the uh
everybody right yeah like I'm the
blackest [ __ ] kiddo there is
and uh I want to point out all the rest
of them you know just ridiculous
sometimes for somebody that hasn't uh
and I wish I didn't gossip as much
because I tell you what me and some of
them girls get around we'd be some
Pretty Petty hateful [ __ ] it would
not one of us has our [ __ ] going on for
us either you know
is whatever yeah
all right Angie thank you so much for
sharing your story no problem thank you
I wish you the best of luck out there
thanks thanks
I so wanted to do that without crying